love time what good you know vlogging
twice a week is kind of rough especially
cuz I headed Mon [ __ ] I got its pimple
on my neck she looks like a third nipple
you ever try to hit on the girl with a
[ __ ] nipple on your neck that's the
only [ __ ] she looks at such how I talk
to somebody and having a completely
exposed breast no no no eyes appear
respect my mind
[Music]
Oh what is going on YouTube what yeah no
what the hell's wrong never doing a lot
of questionable [ __ ] on these blogs now
grown up I always assumed that everybody
was taught a certain amount of etiquette
at a very young age what am I talking
about I'm talking about manners that's
right you said the [ __ ] I said it
matters
yeah look I'm telling you right now if
we live in a world without any formal
respect and not knowing how to treat
each other properly I would be punching
everybody in the goddamn throat why the
throat you ends because the throat is
the ball sack of the face and so because
a lot of us that have forgotten these
simple rules of respect let me refresh
your memory
that's French it's right memory so yeah
we know what is LGI baby let's get it
God number one say excuse me you dumb
[ __ ] now a lot of you may ask well can
you apply this word excuse me in a lot
of different situations you [ __ ]
neanderthal for example use it with
somebody's in your way thanks to me
use it when you burp or fart we cover
the mouth part yeah oh it's do miss boo
and especially use it when you fire mmm
excuse me uh what is that smell oh now
you can't tell I'm Asian I swear all the
Asian people have the hardest time using
this phrase because I honestly think
that this brings in most Asian languages
does that exist
you know what excuse me is in Cantonese
oh you're right wait perfect example mom
mom farts all the time she never said
excuse me you know what she says your
work a shaky the water to the boy who
grabbed up my mother - pokémon - so
number two say thank you when someone
does something nice for you just [ __ ]
say thank you why you ask because it is
a sign of gratitude you ungrateful lump
of pubic hair yeah
how many times have we done some stuff
out of our way to do something nice for
somebody and all you've got was a ha I
did your story I'm a friend who went out
of his way in the middle of a freeway to
change a man
fire in the pouring rain all he did was
stood there watching after he was done
he just left you know at this point it
just makes you want to slam doors in
people's faces and ninja kick baby
turtles into a pool of boiling tears
what I don't know what you thinking cuz
some of you might have four people 490
me turn taste what they say [ __ ] shut
your philosophical ass up ain't nobody
give a [ __ ] I just want some I say thank
you make me feel bad for that [ __ ] to
hell out of you fine chop you right here
left here lovely [ __ ] make you go death
like it not free when you mess up say
sobbing personally one of the things I
hate doing is having to wait for an
apology when I deserve one you know
you're wrong I know I'm right
you know that dude I was at a restaurant
and this do messed up my order and you
know how that [ __ ] went down
excuse me actually order the con will
play not the side salad now you only
ordered the side salad no I ordered the
combo plate you can check me if you want
okay whatever you order what you want no
ma'am I'm up late your own hair weave I
don't know what the [ __ ] you said but
this [ __ ] just call me [ __ ] yes over
you let me tell you something I am 239
pounds why the [ __ ] would I ever order a
side salad for the meal you know what a
salad is a salad is the [ __ ] you eat
before your meal like I ordered grass
clippings for a meal get the [ __ ] on out
of here
[ __ ] don't even make sense makes me want
to elbow somebody in the face just oh oh
oh to be honest with you I'm trying to
figure out why this common courtesy
thing has disappeared where has it gone
but I'm just gonna warn you guys out
there because one day you just might
meet a crazy [ __ ] like me what's
up with the gang signs all day
here's the fighting tip from Davis cells
of the day when you fight somebody just
use your elbows only you look crazy ass
[ __ ] ain't nobody want to fight somebody
who just using their elbows you know
what you look like you look like a
mentally challenged crab and [ __ ] what
Giada teach you how to dance just so I
can break your kneecaps oh you never I
don't have any [ __ ] sense of some
American I'm a madman
look I'm telling you right now if we
live in a world where we do not donut
donut dad you say donut during this [ __ ]
oh my god I'm hungry as hell back no
excuse me
all right there see